BALAJI RAJAM: Thank
you, everyone,
for joining the session on
"Accelerating application
development with Anthos."
This is a rough
agenda for today.
We'll have a quick introduction.
We'll talk about challenges
of application delivery today.
We'll talk about application
development with Anthos.
And then, we will get into
how enterprises can migrate
from PCF using kf and Anthos.
A quick introduction
about myself.
My name is Balaji Rajam.
I've been at Google
Cloud since 2016.
I am a Solutions Manager with
the Application Modernization
Team.
First, let's talk about the
challenges of application
delivery today.
We have been talking to
customers about the challenges,
what they are facing.
And they have talked to us
about their business objectives,
as well as their
technology objectives.
As far as their
business objectives go,
most enterprises are
looking to accelerate time
to market for new
capabilities and features.
And especially in
the current climate,
costs are on top of their minds.
So they are looking to
reduce costs as well.
How this translates into
technology objectives is they
are trying to drive speed
and agility using automation.
They are trying to improve
developer efficiency
through self-service.
They want to have a unified
operating models across on-prem
and hybrid or multi-clouds
because most organizations have
started adopting public clouds.
And security is also top
of mind for most folks.
So they want to ensure
whatever solution they choose
has the best-in-class
security and compliance.
But if you look at those
points, traditional software
development and
testing and deployment
has not really kept
up with those demands.
Let's see, look at some of
the reasons why it has not.
Traditional enterprise
software development
was developed for
the on-prem work.
So it has several
limitations when
it comes to addressing most
modern application delivery
models.
Traditional enterprise
software development
relies on imperative thinking,
where things are much more
specifically defined, whereas,
more modern application
development relies on
a declarative approach.
Previously in
enterprises, applications,
once they're developed, they go
through a security evaluation
process.
And that is how they get
approved for deployment.
And that usually comes towards
the end of the software
development lifecycle.
What that means is
it becomes a choice
between fixing the
security issues
and going into production.
Enterprises are looking to
change that and incorporate
security into every phase of
their software development
lifecycle.
Increasingly, companies
are also starting
to adopt open source software.
And that is causing them
to rethink how they test
as well as deploy software.
The typical governance
models, which
are in use within
organizations, were created
for the on-premise work.
And those have
not really kept up
with the kind of rapid
deployments, which
you see in companies who
have adopted public cloud.
And those also need to change.
DevOps Research and Assessment
is an organization, which
does research on these topics.
And this is a company, which
Google acquired a little while
ago.
They published a report
in 2019, after talking
to a lot of enterprises
about the state of DevOps
in those respective
organizations.
And they had some key findings.
The first one was delivering
software quickly, reliably,
and safely is at the heart
of technology transformation.
And it really effects the
organization performance.
Most companies come
from the on-prem world.
And they bring that approach
to public cloud as well.
And that is not conducive
to optimum performance.
So how you implement your cloud
infrastructure really matters.
The other one is the change
approval process, which
are prevalent in enterprises.
And those can be
pretty antiquated,
which goes through many
hoops before you can get
approved on the cloud software.
And that has to be
reduced, so that you
can cater to the modern
development approaches, which
are prevalent today.
So when the DORA team
looked at the organizations
and tried to evaluate
them, they evaluated them
on four key parameters.
The first one is the lead
time required for deployment.
The second one is how
often can you deploy.
The third one is how quickly
you can recover and change
in case of a failure.
And the last one was what is
the time required to restore
in clear case of an issue.
So they broke these metrics
into different categories.
And based on these
parameters, they
classified organizations into
elite, high, medium, and low.
And if you look at the
elite organizations,
they have on-demand
deployments, where
they can do multiple
deployments per day.
And they have a change
failure rate of less than 15%.
And when you come to the
low-performing organizations,
they deploy maybe once a month
or, in the worst case scenario,
once every six months.
And they have change failure
rates which are really bad.
But if you look at the
majority of the organizations,
they fall in the middle.
Around 67% of organizations
they evaluated fall
in the high or medium category.
But all of these
organizations have a desire
to shift left and become more
elite in their performance.
So this is where
developing with Anthos
comes in because Anthos was
built from the ground up,
to cater to these
kind of requirements.
So Anthos was the result of 15
years of Google's innovation
in this area, right from 2003,
when Google engineers created
Borg, which, again, became
open sourced as Kubernetes, all
the way up to 2019, when
Anthos was released.
So let's see how Anthos enables
cloud-native development today.
The first aspect which a lot
of our customers are looking at
is security.
They want separation
of duties, so
that developers and the
activities they'll do
are separated from the
activities, which the operators
and deployment folks do.
They want effective
vulnerability management
and being able to have
effective access controls.
They want to be able to
define their infrastructure,
both as code as well as
the application platform.
It allows them to automate
the activities which they do,
so that it is better
auditable and it can
be controlled better as well.
Effective deployment
of applications
mean that they
are containerized,
so that they can be isolated
from other applications
and they are extensible
and transparent.
And most organizations
are concerned
about being locked into
a particular vendor.
So it has to be
open-standards based.
And Anthos satisfies
all these criteria.
So let's look at
how Anthos enables
elite DevOps performance today.
It reduces the
developer platform
because it shields
developers from knowing
the details of the
platform, so that they can
focus on value-add activities.
It establish governance
and separation
of roles across
application life cycle.
And organizations are able to
centrally control configuration
and policies across
applications and themes.
It also allows them to
leverage existing investments
and skill sets because
Anthos is based Kubernetes.
And it can run on
any cloud platform.
And it also provides
them the flexibility
to build, test, and
run their applications
wherever they choose.
So these are a couple
of our customers
who have used Anthos to increase
their DevOps performance.
Kaeser Kompressoren is one
of the leading manufacturers
of compressors in the world.
They use Anthos to modernize
existing applications
on their current infrastructure.
HSBC used it
slightly differently.
They used Anthos to accelerate
their software velocity
in a hybrid environment.
Next, let's look at how you
can modernize and migrate
your Cloud Foundry applications
using Anthos and kf.
This applies to both Pivotal
Cloud Foundry applications,
as well as the open-source
Cloud Foundry applications.
So when we spoke
to PCF customers,
this is some of the
insights we had.
PCF came into popularity
a few years ago.
And it gained a large
mindshare with customers,
predominantly because
developers really
loved the opinionated workflow.
Developers loved the fact that
they can compile their app,
build it.
They can turn it into
an image and deploy it,
in a short while, through a
simple command, like cf push.
But at the same
time, operators have
been struggling with managing
Cloud Foundry workloads.
So for instance, BOSH, which
forms the underlying technology
of Cloud Foundry,
is not as flexible
or as general purpose as a
platform like Kubernetes.
And [? populators ?]
are increasingly
getting used to using more
declarative approaches
to application deployment.
And they want that same out
of all of their platforms.
And most organizations have
started to adopt Kubernetes.
So now, Cloud
Foundry becomes yet
another platform to maintain.
So they are maintaining a Cloud
Foundry platform, as well as
a Kubernetes platform.
And especially if you're
using Pivotal's Cloud Foundry,
it means that you are
paying a lot in licensing
cost or subscription cost.
The model of Pivotal is based
on application instances.
So every time you deploy a
new application instance,
you have to pay a
subscription cost to Pivotal.
So that essentially
discourages architectures,
like using micro services,
because that is predicated
on deploying multiple instances
of an application to scale-up
and so on.
So given that, people are
looking for better ways
to do that application
development.
So we spoke to people
from different parts
of the organizations.
The two personas we focused on
was developers and operators.
And we focused on what
are the things which
are important to them.
So for the developer,
they really
want an opinionated
workflow, where
they don't have to worry
about the underpinnings
of the platform.
They want to compile, build,
and deploy images easily.
They also want to be
platform agnostic,
so that when the company decides
to move from one platform
to the other, they do not
have to come back and change
something.
They also want the option
to move to a zero-ops model.
On the operator
side of the house,
they want really want
declarative platform
management.
Organizations which have
moved to a public cloud
have used things like
Terraform to automate
and make it more declarative
to create the infrastructure.
So they want that same out of
their application platforms
as well.
They want to be able to
apply common policies
across enterprise, so that
they can standardize on how
they operate the platforms.
They want higher visibility
into microservices
because enterprises
are increasingly
adopting microservices.
And it is vital to them to
understand the information
behind those.
And probably most importantly,
as most organizations
are starting to
adopt public cloud,
they are looking for ways to
limit their operational cost.
And that can only
happen if you can
have a unified control
plane across on-prem,
as well as public cloud.
So this is where kf comes in.
kf was developed by Google,
from the ground up.
So what it allows developers to
do is use kf in the same manner
they would use CF commands or
the Cloud Foundry commands.
They can issue a
kf command, which
will interact with all
the underlying components
of Anthos, to provide the same
experience which developers
would have when they
use Cloud Foundry.
Operators, on the
other hand, can
use all the
declarative approaches
provided by cubectl and
all the Kubernetes tools
to manage the platform.
So what is kf?
So the kf is meant to provide
developers the Cloud Foundry
experience, while empowering
operators to adopt
declarative practices.
We allow organizations to
move their Cloud Foundry
applications to Anthos,
without causing any disruption
to their developers.
kf is build by Google,
from the ground up,
natively on Kubernetes.
We do not use any of the
Cloud Foundry components.
So that means that
organizations no longer
have to pay the subscription
or licensing cost behind Cloud
Foundry, say [INAUDIBLE].
And administrators can operate
the platform using kubectl.
And below are listed some of the
commands which are supported as
part of CF.
So when we built kf, we
actually brought the best of PCF
to Anthos.
We ensured we had provided a
CF-like developer workflow.
We wanted to make sure that
we are building natively
on top of Kubernetes, so that
we remove any other dependencies
from Cloud Foundry.
Buildpacks on a common
way how enterprises
standardize, how their images
are built and deployed.
So it is very important
to organizations
which use Cloud Foundry that we
provide support for buildpacks.
And that is available
as part of kf.
And we looked at the commonly
used commands from enterprises.
And we added support
for 40-plus commands.
And we also added support
for service brokers.
And service brokers
are the mechanisms
which CF applications
use to communicate
with external open sources.
Technical support for kf is
provided through all Google
Cloud Support channels.
There is no additional
cost to using kf.
kf support is included as part
of your Anthos subscription.
kf is supported both
on-prem, as well as on GCP
and other public clouds.
And standard Google Cloud
deprecation policies apply.
Let's look at a migration
from PCF to Anthos.
So on the left-hand
side, in phase 1,
you see the enterprise
status as of today, right,
where they have CF
applications as well
as Kubernetes application.
And their platform
team is maintaining
two different platforms.
One is Cloud Foundry.
Another is probably a container
platform, like Kubernetes.
So that means that the
operational overhead
is high for the organization.
In phase 2, when they start
adopting Anthos and kf,
now they have a single platform
to maintain, which is Anthos.
The operators running CF
application can use kf.
And the folks running
Kubernetes applications
can deploy their applications
on a Cloud Run or GKE,
or Google Kubernetes Engine.
As the organization
develops a comfort level
with Anthos and
GKE and Cloud Run,
they can slowly start
migrating their Cloud Foundry
applications from using
kf to running natively
on Cloud Run or GKE.
And we do not mandate
that organizations
do that within a
certain amount of time.
They can continue to
use kf until reach
the level of comfort where they
can migrate their applications
over.
And in phase 4, you see the
enterprise has completely
moved over, from Cloud
Foundry applications
to Kubernetes application.
And they are using
Cloud Run and GKE.
Let's look now through
the various phases
of PCF migration.
So there are multiple
paths where you
can migrate from PCF to Anthos.
And we provide different
pathways for it,
for enterprises.
No enterprises are
built the same.
And everybody has
their own challenges.
So we acknowledge it.
So certain enterprises feel
very comfortable moving straight
away from PCF to something
like Cloud Run or GKE,
either on Anthos
on-prem or on GCP,
which is managed by Google.
But other organizations
have their challenges
because migrating hundreds of
apps built on Cloud Foundry
is not that simple.
So they can migrate
to Anthos and use
kf, which will effectively
simplify the operation
because they have only
one platform to manage,
and continue on that pathway
of running the Cloud Foundry
applications, until they feel
comfortable moving to Cloud Run
or GKE.
The first phase of moving
your Cloud Foundry application
from Cloud Foundry to Anthos
is running an assessment.
So as part of the kf tool,
we provide an assessment
capability.
You can run the kf tool against
your Cloud Foundry application.
And it will actually
tell you what,
if it is a good fit
for the kf platform.
So in the next
slide, you actually
see a sample report, which
is generated by the kf tool.
And on the right-hand
side, it's actually
showing whether the migration
assessment has passed or not.
The next stage of using kf
to migrate your applications
is now, to deploy
those applications.
And you can do that through the
simple CLI of kf and kf push.
And you can migrate your
existing applications
to Anthos.
The screen shows an
example of deploying
one of the very popular
applications, which
I used to demonstrate the
capabilities of Cloud Foundry.
It's called spring-music.
And in this case, we are
deploying that application
using kf.
And the developer
expedience will
be pretty much
similar to what they
will see with Cloud Foundry.
Once you have deployed
the application,
now you get to the portion
where you're operating it.
So developers can use the
various command line arguments,
which are required,
which are available,
to operate the applications
which they move from PCF to kf.
And operators can use
the kf installation
with GKE and Anthos tools
to manage the deployments.
So here, you see examples
of some of the kf
commands developers can use
to look at their applications.
They can use kf scale to
scale out their applications.
They can use kf logs to look
at the logs that are generated
by their application.
And operators can use
the various UIs, which
are available, to manage
GKE and Cloud Run,
to actually see what the
status of an application is.
It provides them a
single pane of glass
for managing both their
configuration and policies,
both on-prem and in the cloud.
So they can look at their
configuration and policies,
as well as get deep visibility
into their applications
through services and network.
And your call to action today
is please, review the resources,
which are linked as
part of the session.
If you are interested in
learning more about our PCF
migration strategy, please
reach out to your account team
and please, talk
to us about how we
can kickstart a pilot for
migrating from PCF to Anthos.
With that, I wrap
up my presentation.
Thank you, for joining me today.